A gig on Game of Thrones is a proven career
enhancer. But the show's actors didn't materialize
out of thin air. Most of them had careers
prior to finding their way to the Seven Kingdoms.
And not everything they worked on was what
you'd consider HBO-level material. For your
amusement (and their chagrin), here are early
roles of Thrones cast members during the "pre-Game"
era...
Emilia Clarke
Before she was an international superstar
as Daenerys Targaryen, Emilia Clarke had virtually
no on-camera experience as an actress. She'd
been on one episode of the UK show, Doctors,
and one SyFy Original Movie. Fortunately,
that movie—Triassic Attack from 2010—provided
her with the opportunity to say, "Why, yes,
I do have experience working with giant reptilian
beasts." And that takes you surprisingly far
in the world of Game of Thrones.
Lena Headey
Ironically, Cersei Lannister actress Lena
Headey's first performance for American television
was in the last outing of Richard Dean Anderson
as the one and only...MacGyver.
(MacGyver music playing)
In this TV movie from 1994, Headey plays Elise
Moran, whose father is killed. That sets a
series of spine-tingling events into motion,
which find MacGyver doing what he does best:
saving the day when the odds are against him.
Headey's character survives, and ends up on-screen
at the very end. That means she has the honor
of being the last person to share a conversation
with MacGyver. Why, that's almost as impressive
as being Queen of Westeros...
Alfie Allen
When the opportunity arises to take the spotlight,
there's only one thing to do: take it and
run. That's what Alfie Allen—better known
as Theon Greyjoy—does in the 2004 sequel
to Agent Cody Banks.
In the scene, the student orchestra playing
in front of Queen Elizabeth and visiting heads
of state has to kill time to prevent the G7
Summit meeting from starting. When the call
goes out to improvise, Allen is challenged
to "go for it." So he struts over to the microphone,
slips on a headband, and launches into a German-accented
version of Edwin Starr's "War." See for yourself:
(singing)
Conleth Hill
If you thought playing a character whose main
character trait includes a lack of private
parts was emasculating, you should talk to
actor Conleth Hill. He plays Varys the Spider
on Game of Thrones. And in 2008, the veteran
actor also played an old, bed-ridden lady
in the British reality show spoof, Britain's
got the Pop Factor...and Possibly a New Celebrity
Jesus Christ Soapstar Superstar Strictly on
Ice.
Yes, that's the actual title.
Jonathan Pryce
Character actor Jonathan Pryce has been working
for so many years that it almost seems unfair
to dig through his catalog in search of something
embarrassing. Instead, let's spotlight a project
relatively few Americans know about: his turn
as the Master.
That's right, we mean the long-lived Doctor
Who villain, but it's not an incarnation you
would've seen battling Doctors Nine, Ten,
Eleven, or Twelve.
No, Pryce found himself doing battle against…Rowan
"Mr. Bean" Atkinson? Yes, in a very special
Doctor Who serial made for Comic Relief, Atkinson
played the Doctor and went toe-to-toe with
Pryce before he hung up his weird jacket and
became the High Sparrow we love to hate on
Game of Thrones.
And yes, we know all about Shae and her grown-up
film career before being cast on Game of Thrones.
You'll have to leave YouTube to learn more
about that one...
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which early role of these Game of
Thrones actors surprised you the most.